happy times you're exactly right the
circle is ironically easier to work out
when we go to the line right
um I'm gonna I'm going to uh as I said
before even though I've shown it to you
in component form I'm going to write it
in column form because I think it
actually makes what we're about to do a
bit easier to see so what I've got here
is R equals here's the position vector
and then here is the
Direction vector
okay now I'd love to take some
suggestions it's not quite so easy to
just read off what's going on here right
um like we did with the center and the
radius of the circle can someone give me
suggestions how might we go about
finding the Cartesian equation that
corresponds to this Vector equations any
ideas
yeah very good now this is really
interesting to me right I actually am a
bit embarrassed of this because I didn't
spot this the very first time I was
teaching this course so you guys get the
benefit of me having taught this before
and learned it subsequently just go back
to the syllabus for a minute right it
says make connections in two Dimensions
this is the orange line between the
vector equation of a line R equals a
plus Lambda B and then this equation
here and we we said before this is a
gradient intercept form right gradient
intercept form but as exactly you just
said Ryan
um this this form here the vector
equation alone is not actually closest
to gradient intercept form it's terms of
what it gives us right it's not giving
us an intercept with an axis over here
it's giving us some arbitrary Point
anywhere right so in fact and even I
think an even better comparison even
though it looks like y equals MX plus b
what it really is is is equivalent to
the two point gradient form so if we
want to get the Cartesian equation for
this then the closest thing that we
would use is the point gradient form in
Cartesian form which just to remind you
it looks like this right it's just that
we need to just be careful
um and cautious with what our X1 y1 is
and what our m is all right so let's
actually do the point first because I
think it's it's the easiest which is the
x coordinate which is the y coordinate
the buzz reacts to his wife okay very
good so there's my five over there where
X1 was
um so it goes with the X and then here's
the two which goes with the Y okay so so
far so good and then you have to have a
look at the the direction Vector which
you can see is uh negative two three be
careful think think closely what's the
gradient that corresponds to this
direction vectile
it's um what is gradient how do we
usually Define that
yeah
rise over run so just sort of like
rewire right because this thing up here
has been written as X over y well not X
over y x and then y but we want gradient
which is uh y over X right so it would
strictly speaking be three over negative
two but we don't tend to like writing
negatives on the bottom so I'm going to
write it as negative 3 on 2. is that
okay are you guys satisfied with that
okay now uh this is a little bit messy
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to get this into general form just
because that's easier to work with for
me so get rid of those fractions by
multiplying both sides by two let's
expand the right hand side which gives
me this and then I will get everything
over on the left hand side so add 3x the
2y is already there and then I subtract
15.
okay so I have an equation now right
um I'm going to uh I'm going to call
this equation one because it's pretty
important I'm going to be solving
simultaneously in a minute right can I
just ask you guys though are you
convinced like how how um confident are
you that that is the Cartesian equation
can I ask you this I often do this with
my students in my own classes right on a
scale of one to ten for confidence one
being I just guessed I really have no
idea right and 10 being I would put
money on the table I am sure absolutely
certain this is right where do you sit
on the Spectrum
okay seven eight that's not bad yeah
I'll make a confession to you guys I was
very like I I designed this question
okay you might can you might see like I
hand wrote this question because I
couldn't find a question in the textbook
um or in the agency that did exactly
what I wanted
um and Mrs Iles might know this Vector
notation is a pain to type it's really a
hassle in in word so that's why I've
written it right now I made up this
question and I was still like yeah I
think so
um and so I put this question to you
which I think we should do right now how
can we raise that seven or eight to a
ten what would be a way that I could
know with confidence that this really
has to be the Cartesian equation how
could we like test it out what could we
do
um grabbing something
yeah I could I could just draw a graph
right like we've got we can by the way
just sort of eyeball what's going on
um this sort of uh Point gradient form
here right if I think about drawing some
sort of rough axes like so sorry that's
very messy let's try that again
yeah that'll do
you know five comma two means I'm sort
of going one two three four five and
then I go up two one two so this is the
point in my point gradient form and then
I think oh it's got a gray of negative
three on two right so it's looking
something like that
like so now I don't know about you I
mean general form is easy to to read and
to write but unfortunately I don't have
a good intuition for whether this is
valid or not remember the thing I'm
trying to compare it with right it's
it's this vector equation okay I'm
hoping that this line goes through the
same points that this vector equation
goes through right this is what my um
Cartesian equation is telling me so one
of the ways that I can know to test is I
can just find some points right now I
think you're probably satisfied if we
just find one I hope because we're like
already at a seven or eight right so I
already know I can say it with certainty
that this Cartesian equation it
confidently um goes through the point
that we said uh from the position Vector
right it goes through five comma two
because by definition like if you have a
look at this here I don't feel I need to
test that right I'm like I know it goes
through there but how would I find
another point on the line
um what would I do with the vector
equation to find some other point
somewhere that exists on that line
any value for Lambda
land pick a value that's easy to
substitute that will just give me some
coordinates and then I can find out like
I can confirm that those coordinates are
on the Cartesian equation right so again
not that you have to do this um when you
are you know in an exam and you're sort
of rushing along right but I just think
it's very important that you everywhere
you possibly can don't rely on like
don't go to the textbook and check and
see like oh does its anti-match what I
think because how do you know the
textbook is right like you're just
trusting a human being uh use the logic
and the knowledge that you have so let's
test Lambda equals one and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to put it into
the
um equation that I had it before so that
gives me this right I'm going to have
five two plus well there's a one there
negative two three so what does this
give me uh what's five take away two
three
and then two plus three is five okay so
I've got coordinates and now I need to
see if those coordinates are going to be
on my Cartesian equation right so I'm
going to substitute
um say for example the x value
into
um the the equation that I had up above
right so I'm going to go equation one
and when I put the X in I get 3 plus 2y
minus 19 equals zero so I'm solving for
y here right and I'm hoping that I'm
going to get
um the right answer here say it again
sorry
oh yeah of course it is I was
substituting Lambda I was looking at my
equation thinking you know something's
gone wrong uh yes three lots of three so
now you can see when I uh do nine take
away 19 gives me a negative 10 and when
I add that to the other side I don't
even need to like continue this line of
working because I know it's going to
land me up on this y value that I was
hoping for before so are you guys
satisfied with that that we have after
we got our arithmetic right thank you
Mrs Iles
um we have confirmed that this is the
right line okay it goes through two
points where we're good
so far so good
okay so I've got at the moment let me
just highlight it for you
um I have a Cartesian equation for the
circle I've got a Cartesian equation for
the line and now I'm going to put to you
I'm going to give you a few minutes
maybe you've already started remember
the question was not just to find
Cartesian equations it was to use them
to find points of intersection okay so
I'm going to give you a few moments I've
already worked this out but I I don't
need you to like just watch me write
this out I think you guys can have a go
and then can you just signal to me when
you've got some points of intersection
and then we will continue so how are you
going are you ready for me to sort of
reveal an answer now
yeah okay fantastic before I go to my
working which I've um I've uh here's one
I prepared earlier Down Below on my
screen I just want to point out
um as you were just mentioning Mrs Iles
we kind of can't avoid doing this by
substitution and because in my circle
equation I've got an X and I've got a y
um it's sort of it's a choice like do I
get Y in terms of X or X in terms of Y
and what I chose to do was you can see
it here on the right hand side because
uh Point gradient form of an equation
already has a like y on the left hand
side it's almost the subject of the
equation right so it's quite close to
um gradient intercept form as it were I
elected to just modify it a little bit
and it does look terrible I will admit
um I was actually a little concerned as
I was crafting this question I was like
oh that that doesn't look fun that
doesn't cancel nicely but I had some
faith that it would work out because I
chose the numbers on purpose so I've
called this equation 1A when you um this
is just another side note when you're
solving simultaneous equation friends I
used to when I started doing these as a
student I'd call them equation one and
then two and then three and then four
however there's danger there because if
say for example equation two comes from
equation one like if they're directly
related if equation two is just a
rephrased version of equation one
if you lose track of what your equations
are when you substitute equation
equation two into one because they are
the same equation you end up with
something unhelpful like one equals one
and you're like yeah I knew that but it
doesn't give me any progress right so
you've got to substitute different
equations into each other which is why
you can see I've named this equation 1A
because it came from one and I guess to
round that out I should call this one
equation two
um because it's it's the second equation
that I'm going to substitute into Okay
so so here comes my working what I'm
going to do is I'll try and reveal it
line by line and you guys can sort of
compare with me if it you ended up
something similar okay
so there's the first thing it's just a
straight substitution I've just put it
into the circle equation right and I've
just highlighted there in blue where
that part of the um the straight line
equation came from right now you will
also notice I did a sneaky thing here
it's not exactly a substitution because
what is that term where did this term
come from
yeah that's right and you can see why
I've put it as 16 on two because I and
these fractions got to talk to each
other right so I put the common
denominator now once you do that you get
this you've got the three on two there
and the first thing I noticed I don't
know if you guys went to straight expand
but I thought oh common factor that that
would like it would be nice to get rid
of that so that's exactly what I did but
just notice you have to be so careful
here right and this is why some people
don't eliminate a common factor and it
still works out right maybe this is what
you did because the three on two there
that I'm factoring out it's not just
three on two it's three on two squared
right now maybe you feel comfortable to
just go immediately to the next line and
just say oh that's nine on four right
but for me I'm quite skeptical of my
ability to get that right the first time
so I wrote this three on two squared to
remind me that um what I'm doing is
actually taking out something that is is
inside the brackets okay
um I looked at this line I don't know if
you got to a similar like this but I
thought ah fractions I get rid of them
as rapidly as I can so therefore you can
see on the next line I've multiplied
through by four
um and that made me see oh there's a
four and a nine and the number on the
right hand side is is obviously
um a multiple of 13. so that showed me
that I could do something further by
noticing that do you see what I've done
here oops don't rotate that
um just like I took out a three on two
squared I can take out a negative one
squared which is nice because negative 1
squared is just one right and what that
gives you is uh x minus 1 squared here
and x minus 1 squared here so in fact
I've gotten away without expanding
anything which I know was a bit sneaky
but I kind of um yeah I designed the
question to do exactly that so I'm
actually just going to delete all that
out so you can now see the rest of the
working here
um I've combined the four and the nine
lots of x minus one squared there I
divided through and then I took the
square root of both sides okay so are
you following are these the points that
you got
Happy Times okay now just to like you
know double triple check again just like
we did before
um if you wanted you've got the
Cartesian equation of the line and the
circle and now you've got points right
so one of the things that I would do is
say go to Desmos and put these in and in
fact I've already done that and there's
our Circle there's our line and um you
can content yourself that it works okay
that was part a well done
um